will Tony's first PhD student right
that's right
and then did postdoc with a lot of us
and
I was doing a lot of cool things
that's debatable
so when I when I first heard about this
event from antonina I was at once very
excited to come and show my admiration
for Tony
but also terrified to be addressing a
computer science audience for the first
time in 15 years
and I remembered something comforting
which is I was terrified 15 years ago as
well
so it's no different
as I said I don't uh I don't get much
time to think about Theory stuff but I
am trying to pass it on to the next
Generation maybe these are my children
and they're reading a book that Tony
could have written
don't let the pigeon use formulas
[Laughter]
so I'd like to start by just giving a
brief uh kind of timeline of my
relationship with Tony
um
hopefully it will elucidate some of her
I grew up on the on Mean Streets of
Cambridge Massachusetts
naturally in order to fulfill my
academic Ambitions attack my bags for
Tucson Arizona
and I actually went there because of
Tony not that I knew much about her I
just knew she worked in theory of
computation and that sounded kind of
catchy to me
I was I was obviously very self-involved
when I first met her because I had an
entire meeting with her without
realizing she was very pregnant and
that was miles to show you how long ago
that this was
[Music]
yeah so it came as a total shock to me
when when I saw her a few weeks later
and she was carrying a baby
[Laughter]
in my defense I think this is partly due
to Tony's kind of nonchalant attitude
um
she's not the type to let even very
extraordinary circumstances prevent her
from being present with those around her
and that's one of the things I really
valued about uh working with her
um it wasn't very long after that that
we started working together that uh Tony
invited me to go to my first conference
which was stock 1999 in Atlanta
um
and I hadn't done any real research yet
or anything and I I didn't have the
background to understand most of the
talks
but that's that's another facet of
Tony's Brilliance which is uh she
includes you no matter what you're
bringing to the party
um
because you know it might might just be
the anchovy flavored Jello that turns
out to be the hit
one of the things I
was introduced to during this trip was
Tony circle of friends and close
colleagues which there were many but
just to to show a few that I remember
meeting at that time some of them were
represented here today
Russell run
um
one thing that became clear to me from
the very first day of the conference
people really enjoyed working with Tony
people's faces would would brighten when
they saw her
um and even a novice like me could piece
together that this might have something
to do with their willingness to engage
on a meaningful level
um with everyone and her remarkable
ability to do so
um in time I had the privilege of
working with some of Tony's uh closest
colleagues and I found that they shared
her passion not only for the work but
for the human connection with with
people that they work with
this was also my first opportunity to
have a fresh Krispy Kreme donut
which I highly recommend if you ever get
the chance
so
after about a year of working with Tony
in Tucson
um she told me that she and Rich were
planning to move to the University of
Toronto
um where they had been grad students and
I was gearing up to fight my
disappointment uh but then Tony told me
that maybe I could come with her and
finish my studies there
and of course I jumped at the chance
so uh
not only because I was you know young
and looking for adventure but because I
could keep working with Tony
um and it was that Toronto that I met so
many um people who would influence both
my studies and my life
um some of whom are here uh antonina
Valentin
um some of whom are not Allen Ford and
Steve Cook
um Aleister I think he's going to
participate as well
great
it was also where I got to know Tony and
her family a lot better
um and she was not only generous with
her time and her ideas but she also kind
of lets you in and makes you feel
welcome no matter what the setting
so I actually learned a lot from from
visiting Tony and Rich's house where
they lived with their kids zelical and
miles
it was not always the neatest house
I remember being shocked one time after
it got a professional makeover and it
looked completely different
um but it hummed with activity and
everything that needed to get done
always did
um despite three kids and and two
parents with very demanding professions
um one of the things I think of when I
think of Tony is her ability to take an
infinitesimal Quantum of time and
quietude
and to do something incredibly
productive with it
um and her brain never seemed to need
any warm-up uh there were always ideas
waiting to develop at any moment
and now that I'm a parent myself I try
to channel some of its ability but only
with varying levels of success
this picture kind of speaks for itself
but this was a
this was a typical day at the office
[Laughter]
so when one of the other people who had
a big influence on my life during my
time in Toronto was this guy after him
again
he came to Toronto as a postdoc about
two years after I started my PhD there
and I have to say I was a little bit
jealous of him
um he was not only smarter than me but
also funnier and that is unforgivable
and frankly I was worried that Tony
would like him better
um as it turned out she suggested that
we all work together and identified
exactly the right topic for us to make
progress on which is another skill she
has
and that experience turned out to be
some of the most satisfying work I've
ever done
um
I remember feeling that the questions
were completely inscrutable
when we started but somehow as we
chipped away at it
utilizing the various areas of expertise
among the people working on it
it became screwable
and the amazing thing is I'm pretty sure
Tony knew this would happen from the
beginning
and that's one of the most important
lessons I've learned from her
even even things that seem impossible at
first and can become trackable in some
cases
in other cases like circuit complexity
they can't
so ever and I became close friends and
he served as sort of a second Mentor for
me
um
of course it was Tony shoulder that I
went to cry on when he left this world
too soon
but back in 2004 things were going well
um and I managed to make it through my
PhD defense
but that very afternoon a much more
minor tragedy struck
I was rushing to move out of my
apartment and I borrowed Tony and Rich's
minivan I don't know if you guys
remember this but to get the job done in
my haste I managed to scrape it along a
brick wall a brick wall
um and needless to say I never worked in
this business again
no in reality Tony uh helped me to
secure a two very fulfilling postdocs
one with Russell
um and now that I
now that I work in Industry
um there are a few opportunities to
reason abstractly but it does come up
once in a while
so I would feel a little bit remiss if I
didn't include at least some technical
content in this talk
uh but I want to start with the
disclaimer this is not novel research
it's
more an application of well-known facts
but their facts I learned mostly from
Tony so I think that should count for
something
um
and moreover the I think the instinct to
ask the underlying questions
um in a setting that's not you know
necessarily open to that all the time
is something I learned from Tony
so I wanted to show this in to show that
her influence is extending to unexpected
areas
so
imagine you're a task in providing
important internet content
such as the third season of the
Mandalorian
to Hungry viewers from across the world
you might need an infrastructure that
looks something like this you have your
racks of servers in a data center
you've got a bunch of routers
interconnected
um
and then you've got links to internet
service providers
this is the one I use from home
so
um
a deployment so I should I should
mention that this this unit here is what
we often refer to as a pop a point of
presence in the industry and
the deployment that consists of many of
these in many geographical locations
within a given part
um each of these links to the different
internet service providers
can reach some segment of the internet
with some overlap due to the tiered
nature of internet service providers
um
and
one thing I've learned from working in
industry is that
sometimes system design and that the
kind of inertia that it implies
can act as a computational constraint so
in this case when a user makes a request
for Content there's a global load
balancer
that decides which pop to send them to
and once assigned to a pop there's a
local load balancer that decides which
of the ISP links we should use to reach
that user
so the llb's job the low the local load
balancer is to find the valid flow when
assigned a set of Demands for the users
so there's
the graph where you have the users or
clusters of users on the left
the providers on the right and the
capacities going to this final node
um
the global load balancer's job is to
make sure it assigns a feasible set of
Demands to that pop because there's not
really an opportunity
to send traffic away once it's already
sent to the bot
so how does the global load balancer
ensure this feasibility well the Min Cut
Max flow tells us that
um the constraints are really that for
every subset of the user clusters
you want the sum of its demand to be
less than or equal to
the sum of the capacities of its
neighbor set in this in this
so but this is a lot of constraints
clearly and the global load balancer can
really only handle a small number so
um
in reality in fact this is a sad State
of Affairs but the global load balancer
is really only good at enforcing
disjoint linear constraints with unit
coefficients but we'll not we'll won't
be too strict about this for now
um
so the question that kind of arose
somebody actually asked this question
organically in the company can we
summarize these constraints with a
smaller set of constraints that ensure
feasibility
um and something in my mind just kind of
perked up to my former days of theory
and it seemed like no
um but how much do we lose if we try to
do that
so this is where the argument takes what
I like to call a Tony and twist
um
so
if I learned anything from Tony over the
years of research it's when you're
trying to prove a lower bound always try
an expander graph
and so that's what we'll do here we'll
use a very strong expander that has
um
so this notation means that the this is
a bipartite graph the nodes on the left
have degree of most d
um and subsets of the left of size at
most Delta M
um expand by a factor of at least D
minus 1 minus Epsilon
to the neighbor set
so
uh and we'll use unit capacities for the
lengths here
so let's associate with each subset U
Prime uh in a point which is uh nrn
and that point will be
um
the expansion factor of U Prime so in
other words the the size of the neighbor
said the V Prime over the size of U
Prime is what this notation here means
if um the coordinate is in U Prime and
zero otherwise
so this point may or may not be in the
valid flow Polito but if it's not then
it's on the uh if it
sorry
if it if it is then it's on the boundary
because one of the constraints is tight
so if you just if you just nudge it a
little bit with Epsilon
um it'll be outside the poly tube
so let's say just for an example you
want to summarize the feasible Solutions
with 100 constraints
our strategy
to refute that is let's pick 200
disjoint subsets
a view of size at most Delta n over two
um
one of the summary constraints must
exclude
at least two of these um what I call
jostled points the the points you've
added Epsilon to
um
and
so let's say those points are p and Q
that constraint is also going to
exclude linear
convex combinations of those points
so preach each non-zero coordinate of
this point P plus Q over 2 is bounded by
D plus Epsilon over two
because they um the degree bound
but in contrast let's consider another
point w where
the coordinates are D minus 1 minus
Epsilon if
if the coordinate is in U1 Union U2
did I say what you want in U2 or
so
U1 and U2 are two of these um disjoint
subsets of size the most Delta n over
two
so
um and it and the coordinates of w are
zero otherwise
so because of expansion W is is a valid
point in the flow polytope
and
so we lose a factor of roughly two when
we compare a point that's included W
with a point that's not included P plus
Q over Q
do you want n u two
uh
oh so we were taking these two
so basically one is out of these two
points where if you there's some point
in the middle that's a conversation
okay
so generalizing a little bit uh
I think you can prove the following
claim which is that for any constancy if
there's an Epsilon such and if you try
to summarize with two to the Epsilon n
constraints
um there's going to be a point
there's going to be two of these points
that have a similar property X and Y
um where
each coordinate of X is less than the
corresponding coordinate of Y
but if you take the ratio of their L1
Norms it's at least C
so
that's I think that's it's a fairly
strong statement that you're not going
to do well summarize at least
constraints
and I think the upshot is that you know
maybe we shouldn't all watch the
Mandalorian at once
um
so just before I conclude I wanted to to
give tony a little present
um
this this is in mint condition
this is a this is a fairly close model
of the car
finally
thanks
thank you so much
thank you for bringing the current to
the picture it was the least I could do
uh questions comments
so is this something that was surprising
to people
um
that's a good question I I would say
probably not too surprising I think it
was just a kind of hopeful wishful
thinking maybe was the question and it's
not actually
there are more constraints involved so
that we don't
we don't even have to consider that
question so we do much worse than that
in general the way we do
and I have one other question have you
gone ice climbing what's that have you
gone ice climbing ever again that's the
story I think yeah I think those days
are behind it
more questions
can you just get something here it looks
like in your work you do use cod from
way back when is it like I wouldn't call
it part of my work it's like sort of a
hobby that uh I can apply it once in a
while but it's not something that's I
wouldn't say it's integral to
the companies
you know operating or anything like that
I wish it were yeah it would be nice to
convince some of that something yeah
okay questions comments solution Studio
world problems
um so in in reality
um
we don't actually decide
we don't we don't really give ourselves
a decision as to which provider we take
um the routing is kind of
we use the bgp the Border Gateway
protocol to tell us which provider each
user will take
um and so
we sort of leave it up to the hands of
fade instead of making an informed
decision
it's like a great deal
okay
thank you so much
[Applause]
we have a couple of hours for lunch
generally people sort of
uh cluster together and group and then
wander often the general directions and
oftentimes find something edible
and we'll be back at 2 30 for montauks
thank you so much everybody